hello and welcome to this video playing
I am broker no name Turkish flag though
let's see what we have playing the
London system now you're taking as the
most interesting let's check we get with
this
after Queen takes I will not be five
interesting position write a six Queen
deform huh
hmm since he wants to provoke f3 on I
can also just develop why not that's
interesting I hope we should be five
this is why it is interesting okay maybe
CSM 94 no no thought in the world about
it now i have a three trying to keep
material I'll go for that 94 I can 94 I
maybe still can play before 93 takes
things now can't you can do that okay
yeah I'm happy to come in for him so
that 94 is no no option here yeah he
will play with the pawn down and tends
to seek for compensation so let's see
the only problem is that of course my
position looks somewhat lucia really
really does
yeah I think I'm castle and see now how
to how to play the same I think it's
good to have see form coming up do
something with the sea to pawn
yeah it's it's more that's a clear porn
the only slight issue is that that
weakened King side but I don't feel that
this is so relevant
yeah i wonder if-if or is a good move
here probably getting control over the
d5 square I shouldn't shouldn't be bad
now maybe just maybe just trade and go
up the one I'll keep it simple and
Knight c3 9 a-4 next i get i get the d6
square for the night this is more
important than having a my bishop look
bad so what now these pawns need to be
need to be supported its susi for a4 b5
this is kind of thing
a 4b 5c six that looks good
okay those pawns I make a strong
impression
it's a bit much really I can take the
six song I a kid Winstead wins it wins
the rope but do I have something better
even no probably not
rinse the full rook rook c6 Roxy 6
Bishop c7 all this so how to how to do
this I belong the seventh-ranked I guess
also difficult now for him to move the
pawns see 5 rupee 7 or b 4 p-7 wins
material before before
c4 look before yeah oh here if I go and
look at 5i should just win the pawn
ok
you
I have to be a little bit cautious
something like if he goes age six or
something check da the soup the one
check and 93 winning winning the
exchange does not decide if I anything
but I want to want to avoid it to give
them any material time 193 is just a
checkpoint check ya know I if I cannot
double the size of Leon the seven-foot
still check check
check check check check it's actually
almost promoting their check check yes
no stalemate him black resins that
turned out to be a really bad opening
position somehow it was very relaxed
about all this getting the porn bag and
so on 24th so it's just keeping the pawn
already and ok Knight f3 turn now he's
not getting it back easily now after a
three one thing that I wasn't sure of is
some let's say here if he can do this
but okay I can take d5 and this isn't
working with here maybe it's in 94 maybe
a move I thought I can go before and the
22 degrees cheeks and oh that's
interesting I was thinking yeah I can
take and play it just play the Queen
because he has to move his Queen i take
c 3 but the engine wants to do this it's
a very interesting continuation
now with this and check check funny can
typically who touches why it is clearly
better well nobody place that now and
after before this is just a pawn down
for nothing much yeah no it's just about
good technical play not sure if my
technical play was good but I felt it
was sufficient unless i blundered
something somewhere i hearby takes a
success possibly has a [ __ ] has a bit
clear up and this yep but that also wins
it's a rogue after all Lucas's too much
okay well thanks for watching